we want people still to go on about
their lives we want people to rest
assured that a lot is being done to
protect them that last blip was from
March 13th just about two weeks ago in
retrospect is that message at least in
part to blame for how rapidly the virus
has spread across the city Jake we
should not be focusing in my view on
anything
looking back on any level of government
right now this is just about how we save
lives going forward that was New York
City Mayor Bill DeBlasio on CNN's State
of the Union Sunday swatting away his
own words as presented to him by Jake
Tapper hello creepy shut-ins and welcome
to the reason roundtable I'm Matt Welch
joined by my video streams colleagues
Peter sudirman Nicholas P and Catherine
mangu ward hi howdy hey Matt happy third
week of the pandemic i pandemic has
lasted longer than that so I hate that
tire check you right out of the gate
although maybe wasn't declared as such
by the always correct World Health
Organization I should say at the top to
listeners and viewers alike please bear
with our metaphorical sawdust and duct
tape and rubber bands and such including
to but not including but not limited to
the sounds of five-year-olds throwing
tantrums around my shoulders and also
Matt I'm not 5 and that was going to say
also please do not judge harshly any
visual information that you might see
unless it's Gillespie's mustache but he
shaved it this is a very podcast which I
really appreciate
that's I did that to help bring the
nation together bad words yes I did
Katherine's eyeliner okay let's start
with a quick every Monday a grim body
count on coronavirus were up to 35,000
deaths worldwide including 2,500 the
United States a thousand of which are in
New York most of which are in New York
City confirmed infections are at
three-quarters of a million worldwide a
hundred and forty five thousand in the
US
60,000 in New York we keep mentioning
Gotham because Nick and I are here at
the epicenter or near the epicenter
which I think it's in Queens a hospital
capacity is being stretched right here
right now it will happen sooner rather
than later in some other cities in
America as well there are rapidly
expanded capacities in places like the
Javits Center the conference center
Central Park has tent city hospitals
being erected right now the White House
over the weekend issued after some
kerfuffle egde and whatnot a travel
advisory for people leaving and coming
to and fro the tri-state area Trump
administration also extended the general
social distancing advisory guidance for
the country to April 30th and also
various officials including the
president have been sort of rhetorically
preparing America to be ready for
between 100,000 and 200,000 virus
related deaths and oh yeah Congress last
week passed two point three trillion
dollar sort of stimulus bailout rescue
mission thingy so there's been a bunch
of journalism including a treason about
actions that governments and others have
taken so far leading us to this point
including actions that have not been
particularly helpful and useful so
Katherine as the editrix of the
operation maybe kick us off here on a
round of government failures or
inadequacies that have gotten us to this
point and hopefully maybe some some
workarounds that we have learned in the
process of getting out of said failures
yeah I mean I think we should go back to
the clip from the top of the show which
of course was the most perfect
distillation of this attitude that we're
getting which is government is
well-intentioned and everyone was doing
the best they could do with the
information they had in anyway let's not
dwell on the past but instead look
forward to the bright future where
government continues to be well
intentioned and do the best it can do
meanwhile government at every level has
failed quite spectacularly in handling
now everyone has failed I personally am
failing right now and just to be clear
we are all failing together as a nation
as individuals but I do think you know
all of us have seen a lot and taken a
lot of guff from this there are no
libertarians and a pandemic line
first of all absurd and insulting it's
not as if libertarians unique among
political philosophies didn't think hey
what if there's a public health crisis
we did but the thing I want to talk
about in particular is the messaging
about masks wearing and masks purchasing
because I think this is a great example
of the kind of government noble lie at
its worst I don't know yet what the new
guidance will be there's been rumors and
counter rumors that the guidance is
gonna change and we should all be
wearing masks ten days from now and in
fact maybe we all should have been
wearing masks all along certainly other
nations have taken that route
potentially to some success at the same
time health care workers need them more
so in fact no one needs masks don't
listen no one needs a mask this kind of
messaging is why people don't trust the
government or why they shouldn't you
know I am a libertarian I don't trust
the government and I still was like yeah
they're probably right I don't need a
mask and now I'm on Amazon trying to
figure out how to buy masks this is not
a failure of libertarianism this is not
a failure of of the private markets it's
it's a failure of government and in fact
if anybody gets us out of this it is
largely going to be all of the people
who tried to figure out a way to make a
buck on making and selling different
types of masks I've bought some on
Amazon we'll see if they come that's a
mistake Katherine I mean yes biome on
Amazon we did too but you of all people
should know that the place to go is Etsy
for mass no I do not want some hippy mat
like that person probably like coughed
on the beautiful hippy mask right before
they shipped it to me I'd like no they
have like a artisanal disease you know
they have like true tuberculosis from
they have like drained that killed John
Keats or something like that you know
what I learned in Iraq protect you from
kovat 19 but it'll have a bird on it
that's true put a bird on I
I do think that part of you know what
what we're talking about here and it is
interesting because like I'm willing to
say you know there's there's no question
that the government has failed and and
that the two major institutions of the
government that are specifically
designed to keep us from being in this
situation the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention and the FDA have
royally [ __ ] up and they continue to
with almost daily new you know
directives to get in the way of stuff
but I think the bigger problem here is
actually that the model in this this is
on a I think ID on a deeper or higher
level than we're normally used to
thinking about this this is more of a
higher key and knowledge problem where
it's like various people within the
government had good ideas or partial
information and they were kind of trying
to push through their understanding and
their their presumptions about what was
best and it turns out that like nobody
had a single best answer for what to do
and that part of the problem here is
less like that the government knew had
bad information too made a wrong
decision and it's more that like you
need a lot of different kind of ideas
bubbling up in a marketplace of ideas
during a pandemic as much as anything
else and that we would have had more
information if if local state and local
health agencies had had more discretion
to test and to do stuff on their own
with that haven't had run it all the way
up to the federal government and get and
get denied we would have been able to
choke off certain parts of the infection
earlier when you look at countries like
Germany there's a piece in The New York
Times which has gone you know back and
forth from you know the New York Times
is you know as they report what they've
report changes but Germany doesn't have
the same kind of top-down health
authority that dictates everything for
everybody and instead they you know they
issue advisories and different
departments or state-level groups then
make decisions like what we really need
here is decentralized decision-making
because a lot of private actors have
really bad information or bad ideas and
a lot of public ones do and so you know
that to me as part of the takeaway here
is that even in this kind of situation
what we need is more discussion rather
than less discussion but john stossel
has a pretty good video
about Germany and other things that I
recommend that he did from his you know
his remote location apartment Sudirman
build on that a little bit what what's
miss steps have you seen taken by the
government so far that have contributed
to where we are today it starts with the
CDC botching the testing rollout process
and then really I think the bigger
failure in many ways was with the FDA so
the way this process normally works is
that the CDC develops the test kit and
that's kind of the standard right it's
not so much the test itself although it
is a test it is the test that then
private companies could be licensed to
produce on mass and so the way this
works is the government develops the the
set of sort of here's what we expect
from a test so at the at the time that
the CDC was doing this there were a
bunch of state labs and a bunch of
private companies that were also
developing their own tests they went to
the FDA and said hey can we use these
and this was in the middle of February
they were asking at least as early as
February 18th and saying we've got tests
that work meanwhile the CDC's test in
addition to just being slow generally
they botched the initial tests and
actually had to recall the test and so
they had just basically start over and
so what the CDC did was create a choke
point and then what the FDA did was say
that none of these alternatives would be
allowed to be used and they didn't
approve other tests until the end of
February despite the fact that the
former head of the FDA Scott Gottlieb
was tweeting in the first week of
February that companies like Roche have
platforms for this stuff they're well
suited they are built to roll out
testing it in for you know in a large
scale and that didn't happen and that
didn't happen because the CDC was a
choke point and because the FDA decided
to ensure that the CDC would be a choke
point and because of that we had very
little visibility on the actual numbers
for people who were infected in the
United States until really this just
this last week
and that has just absolutely hamstrung
our response it has been because we have
been operating blind governors the
federal government haven't known what to
do and
then a huge huge problem that is the
original sin in our failure in our sort
of major failures to respond here is
that we blew the testing process and
when I say we blew it I mean the CDC and
the FDA worked together to ensure that
private companies that are really really
good at this sort of thing couldn't do
their jobs and couldn't make life better
for millions of Americans can I just say
I am very uncomfortable with the number
of times the word choke has been said
already in this podcast if we could we
could just scale that back as a disease
like off no no okay made it worse for
them I am going to take my choke
pointers privilege I know I'll talk a
little bit about the person that we
heard from at the top of the of the old
pod bill de blasio mayor of New York
thankfully there has been I'm sure
everyone has seen by now various mostly
Democratic but also the bulwark kind of
super clips of Donald Trump saying
various things kind of minimizing the
crisis and well the curve goes up like
this and and more and more deaths and
cases and such like well they're finally
starting to do that now with bill de
blasio similar kind of super clips even
from comments that he made as recently
as this month I'm ultimately not going
to talk about all of that and focus
micro microscopically on the schools but
I just want to point out because this is
amazing that on February 10th this is
what the mayor of New York City which is
now the epicenter of the corona virus in
the United States said if you're under
50 and you're healthy which is most New
Yorkers there's very little threat here
the disease even if you were to get it
basically acts like a common cold or flu
and transmission is not that easy
thanks thanks Bill de Blasio oh he's
wrong about transmission but he's not
wrong about the effects of the disease I
mean I I want to throw in the idea that
we are overreacting still but like to
say they are reacting is not the same to
say as it's basically the flu
and transmission is not easy that that
there's no there's no there's nothing to
support that well at that point but
that's I just wanted to throw that as
the palate a mousse bouche but talk more
specifically should that be the thing
that puts a big dollop of phlegm in your
throat rather than here's the mail are
you choking on a moose Boosh so no yeah
I know the it was clear from this
parents of New York City school kids
public school kids that the mayor and
the Department of Education a chair here
Richard Carranza were ideologically
predisposed to not close to school so
there's plenty of arguments should you
should you not close schools I happen to
believe one thing about that but let's
set that aside they were so predisposed
towards that that they would come up
with different reasons for it and as
part of the process
New York Post has done some great
reporting on this they intentionally
they sent directives to schools and to
teachers to not report to not report to
the Department of Health when they had a
positive test there was a teacher at a
school pregnant by the way who tested
positive I believe it's like a March
15th or 14th and said hey look I'm
positive I've been at school all week
maybe we should shut down the school
they're like no not only are we not
shutting down but everyone all the
teachers have to come for a mandatory
like extra training here and since then
a half a dozen of those teachers have
fallen sick as well they have suppressed
information on this is the problem you
can have differences of opinion about
various things but when you're ideology
not only points you in a direction but
also it impels you or in you know
encourages you to suppress information
from people that's when you have all
kinds of danger that comes up what's out
there have you seen I mean there's a
there's a mean going around in the world
and we're all kind of leaning into it
even by the framing up the top here a
beam saying oh this crisis has confirmed
that my prior model of my pre-existing
beliefs are true so let's let's shake
that up a little bit
Catherine since you're so enthusiastic
about that particular mean is there
anything about this crisis in the
response and whatever that has caused
you to explore perhaps the limitations
of your ideological priors I'm about to
give you like a really cop-out answer
but here comes anyway um so yeah like
I'm thinking a lot about this like
behold how the crisis confirms
everything I already believed you guys
are not getting probably quite as many
submissions from outside writers who all
would like to run in reason their essay
about how coronavirus proves their
priors like I'm seeing just a huge
uptick in in that genre in my inbox
alone much less in the world
I will say and this this hurts me so it
is at least somewhat of a real answer to
this question this does not make me
change my underlying anarchist views it
does make me more sympathetic to the
ways that anarchists annoy the bejesus
out of men arcus that's because we are
muddling your messaging which is to say
a lot of a lot of the libertarian
responses to the there are no
libertarians and a pandemic critique
have been hey the thing libertarians
think the state should do is respond to
airborne infectious disease like that's
the one freakin thing the state can do
but of course me out here being an
anarchist I'm like I'm actually I stand
I stand by my actually because as we
discussed at the top of the show the
state is doing a terrible job at that it
does a bad job at all the things we
should have no state however I am sorry
to my fellow libertarians for the fact
that the existence of me and moreover
the existence of louder more annoying
variants of me are complicating your
messaging um just to be clear as always
my anarchism is the most gradualist form
and so I would say yeah once we get rid
of all the other things the government
does we can talk about getting rid of
the part where we try to control
airborne
disease from some kind of centrally
managed power but again just one note
it's going badly is that state capacity
anarchism shut Sudirman talk about how
catherine's the problem oh she's the
greatest boss and editor ever
oh no but uh you know look she's my
current boss an editor so um so she gets
the definition that's like calling
someone your current wife ouch
hopefully my my boss an editor for a
long time here so I will say the rest of
your life really this is this is
confirmed my priors in some ways you
know I wrote that you should play video
games
I believe that beforehand yeah but it
also I it has it has caused me to think
more and about and perhaps a little
differently about stimulus and eken and
fiscal policy then then I did before and
so and even going into this even yet
there's a video in which I interviewed
Veronique Guruji right as this was sort
of rolling out when in which we talked
about the insufficiency of economic
policy responses but when the government
shuts down the economy and prevents
people from working when it is a when it
is a government driven recession and I
assume that that's what we're in I guess
technically we haven't had the committee
that calls this thing or calls things of
recession call this a recession but
we're in a recession right now and we
are in a recession because the
government demanded that people close
their businesses and stop going to work
and stop interacting with the economy
and in that case I find it harder to
make the case broadly against any sort
of large-scale fiscal response that
attempts to pay people back or sort of
to cover for
the days and weeks and months in which
people either can't work or are very
limited in what they can do because the
government has said your business is
closed you cannot get revenue the way
that you planned you cannot go to work
and that's not a ringing endorsement or
anything close to the particular
stimulus package that we passed I
suspect that if nothing else it will be
implemented badly and there will be
minimal insufficient oversight of it I
mean the oversight issue you know where
we're gonna is just gonna be a mess as
they spend all of this money and figure
out who they're gonna give it to
especially on the corporate side at the
same time when the government says you
can't you can't work and that's the
reason you can't work that's the only
reason it's not because you were bad at
your job it's not because there's a
market failure it's not because there
was sort of an underlying condition in
the economy it's because the government
said you're out of work then a large
fiscal response I can see a case for it
in a way that I maybe couldn't have a
month or two months ago I Nick do you
want to confess how much of a
libertarian you no longer are based on
the coronavirus you know I think I had
gone through most of my death and dying
stages years ago so for me the one thing
that this drives home more than anything
you know I've been working I started
working remotely from Reason in 1996 and
my day-to-day life is not substantially
different than it has been for you know
since then for what's that 23 years 24
years around that time and I think what
I'm actually kind of rethinking now it's
less about government policy and it's
more about in the mid 90s I was very
much of a proselytizer for moving online
and kind of escaping not at not escaping
but building a world in the cloud all
right wasn't called to cloud them but
cyberspace and whatnot and on the
information superhighway yet you know
it's funny because nobody used that term
but sorry then you guys missed an
opportunity because I how
and incredible well you always you
always want to paint the future in terms
from like the previous industrial era so
you know we should have been calling it
the celestial railroad or something but
it it's you know it's we we've been
accomplishing that kind of vision of a
migration into a more distributed
decentralize you know both online as
well as meats based reality and whatnot
and I think what we're looking at now is
you know it's a forced migration into a
lot of that and I think there will be
really good and interesting meaningful
shifts that you know in a piece that I
wrote I likened it to you know
cyberspace was kind of like that big
home exercise piece of equipment that
you bought and now you used to put dirty
clothes on never got around to use and
we're doing that more and in things like
education in particular in medicine
we're finally seeing people getting
their asses in gear to actually start
doing stuff in a mix of online as well
as you know kind of in what will
eventually come back to being real space
and things like that but that it's
actually it's if we haven't theorized
you know a kind of a post you know 20th
century world very well and I think this
will hopefully you know what what will
come out of this is is a better mix of
really using all of the online stuff as
well as kind of really sharpening the
you know the case for meat space it's
weird when you go outside even in places
like New York you know map where you and
I are you know most of the restaurants
are kind of shitty and mediocre they
haven't really they didn't really build
up the physical space because they
didn't have to yet and so I'm not sure
that this gets at your main question but
what I'm looking forward to coming out
of this is a richer appreciation both
for what cyberspace or you know cloud
whatever you want to call it needs to be
doing to really have people inhabit
there but also you know the rest of our
lives so that you're not going to
mediocre restaurants anymore and whole
cities are like that I spent a good
chunk of the past 20 years living
outside of Cincinnati it's a good
example of a midsize City you know it's
not smaller than New Orleans or you know
or someplace like Savannah
you know other cities and you know that
have a real sense of place but it never
really developed it very much and I
think you know that's something that I'm
looking forward to seeing take off you
know post pandemic I should first of all
not scratch my face but second of all
that's your face of say thank you in a
free country say that one thing that
this is underlined may be in the in an
opposite direction from Nick is I live
in a very you know walkable restaurant
community filled neighborhood and the
thing that keeps me sane in during this
long cabin-fever shining reenactments
that we're all going through is taking a
walk through the neighborhood and it
makes my heart go Pengy Dee pang to see
how many places are closed and and it
sort of makes me makes me realize anew
how much the thing that makes me happy
is to see bustle and to see humans
interacting and to be part of it and to
set out my front patio and wave and call
the neighbors over to have a drink and
all that kind of stuff on and it's all
good I'm talking about it's like why are
you haven't calling the neighbors over
rather than going to a corner bar that
is fully inhabiting what a corner bar
should be as opposed to just being like
a half-assing it that's a much of it I'm
having the opposite experience which is
I have always been team Matt on this
front that like the best and most
beautiful landscape is like an urban
street where all the shops are open and
some people are eating food like that's
that's my optimal environment however
this has forced me to do nature I have
been doing this on nature did you do
that thing with your eyes again that you
just did right before the word nature
I'm not sure it was so spontaneous I
can't recreate it because that's how I
feel about nature I don't really like
the outdoors very much but my children
are antsy and we have Rock Creek Park
here in Washington DC which is beautiful
and so I found myself genuinely
recreationally putting my hands on dirty
rocks like and kind of enjoying it and I
was like oh I see interesting so you
know there is a flip side which is like
when the optimal bustling commercial
street is not available you know
nature's alright I guess nature is the
ultimate product of the Industrial
Revolution the Broad Creek Park
certainly yes
like like lemon carve a chunk out in the
middle of a city - dude the nature in -
so that the grubby working-class people
can commune with nature and be less be
steel a criminal crime probe it's
working right now sudirman talked about
the stimulus and and his own weird
fondness for it so let's talk about that
a little bit you've already Peter talked
about your own kind of confessionals I'm
very excited Matt that the Kennedy
Center in you know got twenty five
million dollars and immediately started
laying off people in the stimulus which
goes to the large point and Peter I
think you will your point has taken that
when the government shuts everything
down you know they have a certain level
of responsibility but this bill is going
to be the biggest landmark in the number
of companies and Justin Amash was
tweeting about how United Airlines got
freaking bailed out and immediately sent
out letters like firing people well even
better did the airline is the airline we
they got their money on the condition
yeah they wasn't anybody I believe it's
September 30th and they sent out notices
then saying that everybody was
furloughed or fired on October 1st it's
perfect it's the one time that they can
really guarantee on-time delivery right
this the the stimulus is a bet or
whatever we're calling it is a bad bill
by design and conception and it will
lead to you know if not rune it is going
to be as bad as the bailout after the
financial collapse and it's gonna be as
bad as all the money that was poured
into a bunch of stuff that we can't even
identify anymore after 9/11 there is no
question I think from a libertarian
perspective you know what do you do when
you are faced with this kind of like
system-wide problem what what is the
role of the government in maintaining if
not the economy because who cares on
some level about you know this indicator
or that indicator of the stock market
and it's more how do you guarantee you
know a minimal level of mass health and
you know suitability for continuing to
live and all of that kind of stuff but
there's no question that this bill is
not designed to deliver that and it
won't
that'll come by because of private
sector activity and things like that but
this is a nightmare
and it's only get it's gonna take us
decades to understand the full contours
of that nightmare sudirman you are the
resonance process geek on this podcast
talk about the process of this bill and
what that says about the way that
Congress has been devolving over the
years the process here was welp we
closed down the economy better spend a
lot of money real fast and then they
kinda came up with some ways to do that
and because they were trying to do it
real fast democratic staffers who were
writing the actual legislative text in
particular just dropped in a whole bunch
of junk a bunch of Democratic priorities
and tried to sneak those in because when
you're trying to spend money really fast
there isn't time to actually go through
and read the bill and read the bill text
and in fact this it already happened
just a couple of weeks prior where we
had this relatively small only eight
billion dollar kind of initial recovery
package and they had to go through and
do a bunch of corrections on it in the
days after it initially passed because
Republicans voted for the thing and then
found out that Democrats had stuck a
bunch of junk into the bill that they
wanted to remove and then it would there
was an issue there because Democrats
were like well we don't obviously want
to take that out and so you know
there's a lot of kind of really grubby
partisan politics as usual going into
this and you combine it with the fact
that it's it's in fact very difficult to
write good legislation even in the best
of times even when you're not trying to
spend two trillion dollars two-plus
trillion dollars on an emergency basis
and so what we ended up with was a kind
of a grab bag of money for middle-class
earners money for corporations expanded
unemployment benefits that in some ways
look if you want to talk about that we
should probably talk about this
provision specifically because it I
think it hasn't gotten enough attention
amongst sort of libertarian types who
have been focusing on the corporate
bailout angle the unemployment insurance
expansion here provides an extra $600 a
week for four months $600 a week that's
$2,400 a month plus whatever
unemployment insurance you might be
getting already in most states it's
about 350 375 dollars a week and it also
expands the number of the universe of
people who qualify for these
unemployment benefits and so people are
going to be getting $900 plus a week
because of this for four months do the
math there that's something like thirty
thousand dollars depending on your
exactly your family structure especially
if you include then the $1,200 that
you're also gonna get just for being
someone who is a middle class earner and
so there is now there is now an
incentive I think that is real for
people who were making who are working
minimum-wage jobs to ask their bosses to
either fire or furlough them and to and
to end up taking getting more money from
unemployment insurance and so if you
look at what the kind of the
state-of-the-art and neoliberal policy
response from to to the coronaviruses is
to do what a bunch of the countries in
Europe namely the UK and Denmark are
doing which is for government to pay a
large percentage of payrolls provided
you keep people on on the payroll
provided you don't fire your workers the
whole idea is this is a time in which
shut down a lot of work and therefore
employers are gonna fire a lot of people
what you want is to keep people attached
to the labor force right we're trying to
put the economy in an induced coma and
then you will be able to bring it out of
that coma as quickly as possible and
when you comes out of the coma you want
all the parts that were attached
beforehand to be still attached but if
what I forgot so what the government is
doing here with this provision is on the
one hand they are providing a big
benefit to people who are getting who
are losing their jobs as a result of the
corona virus and I think again like I
said I can see a case for at least some
of that but they are also providing an
incentive for more people to lose their
jobs and they're going to destroy labor
market attachments in the process
there's just a ton of unintended
consequences that are gonna come out of
a rush 2.2 2.3 trillion dollar package
that's one of them the corporate bailout
stuff we should also talk about other
people should should come in there but
there's basically no oversight on it we
remember what happened with the stimulus
oversight where CBO released these
reports every quarter or so and they
were like well we spent X number of
dollars our models tell us that spending
X number of dollars creates X number of
jobs therefore we must have created X
number of jobs they did absolutely no on
the ground checking as to whether any of
those jobs had actually been created
that was left to private - private
oversight outside you know the Mercatus
Center probably did the best work on
that specific question by actually
asking people how they had spent the
money and so there's just gonna be a
huge number of these unintended
consequences of just weird stuff
happening of probably some economic
destruction happening as a result of a
bill that is designed to keep the
economy from falling apart can I put a
happy spin on all of this you know I
think the pandemic both you know in its
government response from the public
health sector as well as economically in
the political realm this is where the
20th century finally goes to die because
they're all of this first off we have to
recognize this in some cases literally a
truly you
yeah it is which it's not you know it
has to happen right I mean you know we
we conjured you know it's not if we're
talking mythologically or symbolically
it's not an accident that this is
happening in the twilight of the baby
boom this is an attempt to move the 20th
century off the stage one way or another
but this is a unanimous bill that both
Democrats and Republicans are fully
behind more than any other piece of
legislation probably in the history of
the United States even even you know the
declaration of war in you know in World
War two
there was one House member who voted
against it you know this is like a
completely unanimous bill and Thomas
Massie you know the libertarian leaning
Kentucky Republican has done something
spectacular by force trying to force a
vote where people were accountable and
and the Patriots in Congress were you
know in the house were so brave that
they didn't want their names attached to
this legislation he got Donald Trump and
John Kerry to get all smoochy with each
other from making fun of Thomas Massie
this is a truly unanimous bill that
shows that the Democrats and the
Republicans ultimately are not different
in their approach to government or their
solutions to crisis etc they've been
bringing us to this stage for the entire
21st century failing more and more
losing more and more people doing more
and more destruction to the economy
Donald Trump is the last act of the
twentieth century this legislation is
the last act of the twentieth century
and there is going to be hell to pay
because there is going to be all kinds
of unintended you know consequences the
intended effects are gonna be [ __ ] up
beyond belief I mean we just doubly we
increase the federal budget you know in
a week you know by 50% what you know how
is that gonna play out this is gonna be
screwed up for a long time but I do
think this is the thing that ends at all
and now we're gonna be looking for
serious alternatives to the status quo
and I think there is a libertarian
response to this which is a smaller
government that does fewer things well
and then there is the maximalist version
which is coming out of the demo you know
the Democratic Socialist idea everything
should be universal the government
should either be too
Klee and charger indirectly in charge of
everything that is the you know these
are the models going forward and I you
know it you know it's it's horrible to
talk about this but we need something to
stand up and cheer for and I do think
this you know if we look at this all and
we push forward as libertarians as well
as people like with pre political or
political affiliations this is the end
of the twentieth century and it's shown
that what was has been we've been using
since the end of World War two doesn't
make sense anymore it does not address
the world it's a map it's a model it's a
projection or whatever that has lost
almost all connection to the territory
that it's trying to describe and this so
you know coming out of this whether it's
in October when those United airline
workers you know are free to like start
living in the 21st century or something
that's when the 21st century will
finally begin I am I worry just a little
bit that it's not over and that we're
gonna do a bill like that again in a
month or six weeks they're gonna have to
I just
I am always always 100% always in every
we're a skeptic of the theory that it's
gonna get bad enough and then everyone
becomes a libertarian it just never does
it everyone think about it we've we see
this in the baby steps of you know
suddenly cities are letting people walk
around with booze in their hand suddenly
you know the FDA and the CDC are going
to eventually have to give up a monopoly
on making bad decisions and let us all
make more bad decisions on her own
school choice is breaking out we're you
know it's it's never easy but there is a
moment where we come out of the wreckage
and and or something different Katherine
Nick mentioned Thomas Massie said the
libertarian moment is 538 bazookas
pointed at Thomas Massie basically yeah
we support the right to own those
bazookas so most important thing what is
that what does it tell you that he is
the most hated person or was until
everyone forgot about it already but for
a few beautiful hours last week he was
the Uniting hate figure of all of
America
yeah I mean I do I do think this notion
that in times of crisis let's hand wave
away all this pesky procedure is a more
dangerous one than people give give
credit and Massey was right to say hey
if we're gonna you know we're gonna
follow the rules like I'm allowed to say
let's put this on the record that's one
of my you know rights and privileges as
of my office and I do think that the
notion that this guy is the problem is
you know is so misbegotten like even if
you don't agree with that tactic right
and you might you might just be like hey
you know what that didn't accomplish a
lot and it was sort of annoying that
would be a fair critique but it is not
fair to say that his underlying point
was wrong his underlying point was
absolutely right that there you know the
time when you need to follow procedures
and follow the rules and read the bill
is more in times of crisis and I think
you know we should have learned that
from the Patriot Act we should have
learned that from the authorization of
use of force we should have learned that
every time we hastily pass a giant bill
in crisis it lives with us forever and
ever and I think Peter is right and Matt
is right that pretty soon we're going to
think about doing this again and I think
the story that Nick is telling about
people walking around with cocktails and
the FDA letting private companies do
their own tests is it's a nice story but
mostly I think a world with more free
markets and more choices wins when
things are going well when government is
basically status quo and meanwhile the
private sector gets bigger and better
and people learn to appreciate it I
don't think crisis yields libertarianism
and I don't think it yields
libertarianism even if we have to go
through brokenness first when we break
things our tendency as a nation as
humans may be is to just build the state
bigger and stronger and more terrifying
after the stuff is broken I have a
question for you all about the messy
thing does anybody does anybody find any
merit to the argument that the problem
with Massey's call wasn't sort of
the underlying principle that people
should go on the record with their names
for voting for this thing but instead
that what you don't want is to put a
whole bunch of old people in a room real
close together for a long time in a time
other than why did that I guess why then
why did they not do it by names so they
did it by voice vote which meant that
you didn't have to have everybody around
and which meant right you didn't have to
have sort of everybody doing it it no
but everybody know hang as they did not
record the names but no no that's that's
my point is is so that the arguments
against what Massie wanted was a was a
record of the names and the argument
against Massie was if you do that you
gotta bring everybody in some cases on
airplanes back into the building and to
me this just sort of suggests that they
what they should have done is had a
process in place for say emergency
voting online they should have which was
something that had been talked about
after September 11th where there were
like emergency procedures that were
discussed but never implemented again a
failure of procedure here a failure to
think ahead to plan for this sort of
thing this is also like all over in the
private sector people scrambled and
figured out how to do their thing online
or how to not do it and instead what
Congress Doug did because it's allowed
to do whatever it wants is it both
didn't do the thing online and then did
it anyway and that's I think it's fair
to say like that was a worst-case
scenario and nasty pointing that out I
think I think was fair even if in the
end you say you know what we're not
gonna we're not gonna put you know our
geriatric representatives on a bunch of
airplanes and bring them back in it's
incumbent upon Massey's colleagues to
convince him of that it's not just wave
it away and you know go on talk shows
and talk smack about him they didn't
need to convince him they just sort of
decided to ignore him right which they
didn't even do that right like like the
correct thing to do would have been to
in that world's most collegial
deliberative body whatever we call it to
convince each other and talk they have
Skype zoom even if they can't vote that
way
they don't know how to use it and it's a
massive points it out in one of his uh
tweet storms about this that news Nancy
Pelosi who delayed the vote for many
many many days beforehand to try to
tailor it according to her own needs and
so that's crucial time they could have
been spent doing something else I would
also just point out in agreement with
Katherine that today I believe the
Hungarian Parliament's has basically
given Viktor Orban authoritarian powers
over the country like canceling
elections you can go to jail for five
years for fake news having to do with
the coronaviruses those sort of the
emergency procedures we're gonna wipe
away he can issue laws by decree instead
of passing them by the legislature it's
a country that I used to live in and
cover and have a great deal of fondness
for and it's also a place that a lot of
kind of paleo conservatives and then
Trumpy and conservatives and have held
up as an example of a particularly good
leader it's a it's a very sad day and
it's a cautionary tale for what bad
governments will do in this crisis if
you should take take care not to make
the same mistake and one thing that I've
noticed that it's a that's been
distressing among the many other things
that are distressing his people media in
particular I've been fixating on various
things you know there's a big mallet
over here and Donald Trump isn't using
the mallet I'm thinking in specifically
but the defense production act like why
isn't the present what it what kind of
monster is he for not using this law to
conscripted companies to build stuff
which will inevitably be bad probably
the Conscription in the building and
everything associated with it but this
kind of trying to shame the president
who you hate for not taking maximum
power in this time is just a very weird
move and we should all be conscious of
the authoritarian that moves by
everybody in this moment and to sort of
build in safeguards that begin between
the ears before we go
for I don't really to insist on that at
a time when every single private entity
that can possibly reorient itself toward
whatever efficient solution to this
problem it feels like it can contribute
to is doing that I mean to the extent
that any firm anywhere is not didn't
have a meeting among their top
executives and say what can we be doing
to help with this problem what can we be
doing to provide that can like the
people something people want to buy
something that people need like I
guarantee you like you know thousands
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of companies around this country ask
themselves that question the idea that
Donald Trump with his giant mallet can
hit all of these CEOs on the head and
say okay now do the do something that's
gonna solve this problem and that that
will be better than what's already
occurred I think it's so misbegotten and
if people aren't acting right now it's
for a good reason and sometimes that
reason is a regulatory barrier so maybe
let's look at those but to sort of
demand production particularly from
factories or companies where the
government happens to have more leverage
when in fact the most useful production
might come from somewhere else entirely
is exactly wrong well and you note of
this is that things like masks just to
focus on that specifically are regulated
as medical devices and therefore there
are limits on how many masks per day can
be sterilized or produced the FDA has to
approve all of this stuff and instead of
asking for the President to sort of step
up and take more power what we should be
doing is saying hey you should be
releasing you should be ending or you
know or at least suspending temporarily
these regulations probably putting them
up for serious review for after the fact
and saying look private companies that
are ready and capable to solve all of
these problems let them do it and there
are there are I mean we just we know the
for example Battelle says that they
could process eight something like
eighty thousand masks a day and there
are there's a limit put in place by the
FDA of ten thousand why is that limit
there
have no idea perhaps there was some sort
of coherent reason at some point in
history that somebody could supply there
is not one right now and the FDA in
particular is will come in for a harsh
reckoning because they're making a lot
of dictatorial decisions that are
completely on unexplained that maybe
they have a good reason but they're not
giving them mad I want to go back to
though this you know this one question
though of like when do we when do we
gain and freedom and you know there's no
question at first and and I'm not not
trying to put you on the spot but
nobody's expecting the libertarian
moment to you know rise out of Hungary
you know not since the Middle Ages right
probably or something but when in in the
Declaration of Independence we talked
about how the 70s was a moment where
simultaneously you had the most
grotesque kind of beefed-up of
government at the end of the Great
Society under LBJ and then under under
Nixon wage and price controls all sorts
of things happening where the government
was flexing like it hadn't since World
War two really since a wartime economy
and exactly at that moment all kinds of
stuff started to get more free because
people were like [ __ ] it we're not we
don't believe the government the
government is is exercising more and
more control over more and more parts of
our lives and we are going to go
elsewhere and we're gonna do it you know
in in economic terms and in terms of
business development and innovation as
well as lifestyle and things like that
and this is where I do think there is an
analogy I mean I'm not just gonna carp
on this until either I die or it turns
out to be right but there is a moment no
but there you know there there is a
moment where people people have have
lost confidence and Trust have lost
confidence and trust in the government
and many aspects of private you know of
a private life in the private sector
nonprofit sector you know I and and we
will continue to do stuff for ourselves
and I think this is the moment like
where we have to recognize there is a
beginning to a consensus in American
politics you know for different periods
and there is an end to them and this is
the moment where we need to be
wallpapering the
world with alternative ideas that have
not gotten as full of hearing as they
need to because we are at the end of
this all of the great institutions you
know both cultural and economic
political you know you name it of the
post-war era including the post Cold War
era they have been you know they've been
shown not to be up to the task and it's
a question for us how do we map a world
and how do we how do we kind of cajole
people into saying why not give this a
shot I think this is this is the
beginning of that moment it's gonna be a
lot uglier before we get more breathing
space literally in figured just a very
briefly I would would say that we would
need in that in that example or let's
say I'm rooting for it in that example
there to be a someone showing that that
approach worked in this crisis or in
this context as a country or a city
state or something like that there needs
to be an example and right now as I look
around the world it's one of the reason
I'm more pessimistic than I was in 2008
is that the context of 2020 2020 and I'm
not talking about the Beach Boys record
for once is worse than the context for
2008 there's a it's the the competition
for policy the laboratories of whatever
are are in kind of trending in a bad
direction I you know certainly in terms
of economic controls in terms of Public
Health I think when you look at
countries like Singapore Taiwan South
Korea Germany these are countries that
all have strong authoritarian tendencies
or abilities and whatnot the way that
they have acted is having a public
health kind of administration or regimen
regime that actually came in and made a
few quick decisions early that then
allowed for a normalization that's
already starting to take place and I
think that's on one level and I think
we'll see you know the question here is
coming at is China is China the model of
the future you know probably not both in
terms of economics and in terms of
public health and I think that's going
to become more clear as we gain more
information
about their response like you know that
is the epicenter of all of this and it's
you know authoritarian regimes do Newton
do not do well in public health crises
over the long run
and yet as part of that a lot of areas
the world which have yet to really see a
large number of reported tests are going
to see that mom later and then that'll
change the way that we look at all this
right let's go to our end of pot just
because we've move on completely you
want to add one one notable fact about
China is that they have been claiming oh
look we're getting better our response
has you know we are you locking
everything down worked and what did they
do last week after starting to reopen a
bunch of their businesses and things
like movie theaters that closed down a
bunch of their movie theaters again and
now they're saying that it's not really
it has nothing to do with this our
numbers are still getting better but
really closely movies are not good no
but in fact but in fact like what that
shows is like don't listen to what they
say watch what they do and they are
worried about reinfection they don't
think that they have actually stopped
this thing and also watch what they do
is the kicking out journalists to make
sure that no one can watch all right end
of podcast what have you been consuming
during the quarantine dear Catherine I
will start with you I am continuing my
Jane Austen Reading Festival I know it's
ridiculous but I have to say like I
finished Mansfield Park and in
particular the scenes of the amateur
theatricals that they are putting on at
home which end up being a sort of moral
contagion to the neighborhood so good so
on point I have moved on to EMA which is
a little bit lighter and perhaps more
relevant for the Chaeronea the people
sort of monitoring each other's behavior
and and it's good and honestly guys like
I know everyone's like that's ridiculous
but you're wrong and everyone should
read Jane Austen continuing their way
through her great works as the pandemic
progresses speaking of Jane Austen Nick
you listened to a song that was as long
as a Jane Austen novel if I'm not
mistaken it is Bob Dylan's longest
recorded song murder most foul which was
recorded sometime in the past decade
it's not exactly clear when and that he
dropped towards the end of last week and
it starts out talking about that dread
day in November of 1963 or the Kennedy
assassination and then it ends being
this kind of you know brilliantly
dylan-esque rumination about all sorts
of things that have happened historical
events songs individuals movements and
things like that it's to me you know one
of the things that is great about Dylan
is that he is I think the the ultimate
American artists of the post-war era of
the past 70 years and he is dying he's
you know eight hundred years old and hit
the world that he has been chronicling
he hasn't released a new album in an
album of new material in years he's been
going through the American Songbook
he is kind of creating this wonderful
network of connections and meaning where
everything is connected to everything
and it's you know and I I read this
piece as like it is a nice send-off
again to a kind of baby boom America
which is the last emanation of that
post-war
consensus I highly recommend murder most
foul and like all great art now it's
available for free on YouTube there are
already a million commentaries most of
which are kind of an interest thing but
you know it's to each his own
and then when you get bored with that
watch Tiger King on Netflix I I listen
to the song I think I had a pretty
similar reaction to Jesse Walker one of
our three or four Dylan ologists on
staff which is that you start at first
ago like am I really gonna listen to a
17 minute song about the JFK
assassination like why is it so short is
it so short eggs is sort of noodling on
his piano and yeah and it's wonderful
and then by the end you get a little
choked up as he's kind of named
name-calling half of American culture
and including some there's a nice little
obscure Warren Zevon reference
right made me maybe I'll choke up I want
to go next because I think that
Catherine probably has recommended this
before and it's a quarantine thing that
i watch with the kids the homeschooling
and also have a question that's why I
wanted to bring so it's our planet the
the the incredible yeah nature / global
warming documentary with nature
sir nature it's a human contraband this
this is the context in which I have
mentioned this in the past is that
that's my kind of nature the kind of
nature that David Attenborough is
telling me about on my TV screen it is
it's totally propaganda and it is
gorgeous I recommend for any of the
listeners out there or I just suppressed
a very good joke you'll thank me later
with suppression or mitigation
suppression anybody who likes to just
smoke a bowl and trip out on a nice big
beautiful thing don't listen to the
words as much it just sort of see this
incredible visual it's me just like ice
shelves in slow-motion falling down and
and and orcas playing with with penguins
trading them back and forth for fun and
and that's very horrible like wall was
dead anyways its total agitprop of the
global warming is killing everybody and
whatever take that for what is but I
it's been a while since I've like tucked
into some nature documentaries and I got
a question and maybe this is gonna sound
my Eve their [ __ ] right like yeah
god there's not on the same soundstage
that the Apollo 11 when guys who write
professional wrestling probably has like
a whole Vanderpump rules they bow a baby
chick through entire life you didn't
have a camera there the whole time
there it's exactly the same as reality
TV right so they capture fifty thousand
hours of footage and then they cobble
together a story which does not reflect
like a real thing that happened in real
time but it
doesn't matter and it doesn't matter
even more than it doesn't matter in
reality TV because like the baby chicks
not a person like it's not it's like
there's no reputation to like ruin or
live with it what is what about that
wow you really hate animals don't you
guys what about the sound cuz I think
the sound editing awesome are you think
it's like someone with a pair of shoes
like oh I think it's Roni you know
studio using his water it's all man-made
thank God I not smoking the
aforementioned bowls of whatever I like
it that it was family movie night and
also mats just like yes we're going
cocktails I'm a I'm a quitter I can't I
can't like Ringo Starr I don't smoke it
no more Peter what have you been
consuming
besides everyone on the shelf behind you
well you can see most of those bottles
are full for now you know I just I
replace them every cup well it's what
it's like twelve o'clock in the morning
here right or the twelve dude I'm
drinking coffee no I've been watching
killing Eve the first season of killing
Eve on Twitch is a BBC show produced and
written co-produced and co-written by
none other than Catherine's fleabag fave
Phoebe Weller Bridge it is a post Cold
War spy thriller about a yeah do the
dance this is this is worthy for Phoebe
it's a contemporary spy thriller about a
sort of secret Russia desk in mi6 in
which a an agent played by Sandra Oh is
tracking a a mercenary who is a female
killer it's a kind of you know a like a
reductive way to describe it would be as
a feminist twist on the jean-luc are a
spy thriller but it's so so much better
than even that and I would like that
sort of thing to be clear but it's so
much better than that it's just humane
and witty and and like surprisingly
light and deft and funny at times while
also managing to capture some of the
real horror of being of tracking
somebody who is a
completely emotionless murderer perhaps
like Katherine and and it's just it's so
well done it's so enjoyable and it is a
break from our world with the exception
of the fact that you see all these
people walking around London and other
cities and they're all just like walking
around and having a normal one except
with the you know all the like all the
spy [ __ ] aside right but like they're
just walking around and they go to
restaurants and they have coffee
meetings with each other and you're like
oh that's what the world is supposed to
be like and I I kind of yeah
it makes me like a little bit sad but
also it's really well-written and
engaging and I highly recommend it to
just anybody who has ever liked a spy
thriller I've just bummed that a thing
called killing Eve wasn't written by
Bill O'Reilly I think that's his next
thing afterwards all right
that's all the time that we have here
for our first ever attempted videoed
thing hopefully it will be released on
video we'll see it's an experiment and
keep listening to all our podcasts
recent comm podcast the Wednesday
interview of the reason it view on
Wednesday with Nicholas B and so forum
but might see some backlogs and it's
gonna be we're gonna be going into deep
cuts uh yeah classic sign of Soho forum
b-sides
just have those like same super own cuts
from vh1 of like you know oh yeah Google
saying talking about it if you go sick
of all that okay okay goodbye everyone
and we'll see you next week
you